what do you think
would be the first time
when humans cite aliens see aliens in a
sort of
unquestionable way
this
extremely strong and arguable way
we've made contact with aliens
sarah what would it look like obviously
the the the space of possibilities is is
huge here but
if you were to kind of look into the
future what would that look like would
it be inklings of ufos here and there
that slowly unravel a mystery
or or would it be like an obvious
overwhelming signal
so i think we have an obsession with
making contact with events
so uh
what i mean by that is
you know like people have a ufo sighting
they make contact
um and i always think
you know
what's interesting to me about
the ufo narratives right now is not that
i have a disbelief about
what people are experiencing or feeling
but like the discussion right now is
sort of
at the level of modern mythology aliens
are our mythos
in modern culture and and when you treat
it like that then then i want to think
about when do things that we
traditionally only regularize through
mythology actually become things that
become standard knowledge so you know
like it used to be you know variations
in the climate were described by some
kind of gods or something and now it's
like you know our technology picks up an
anomaly or someone sees something we say
it's aliens and i think the real thing
is it's not contact with events but like
first contact is actually contact with
knowledge of the phenomena or the
explanation and so
this is very subtle and very abstract
but
when does it become something that we
actually understand what it is that
we're talking about that's first contact
it's not would you make the myth would
you give credit to the myth the
mythology as first contact
because i think yes i think it's the
rudimentary that we have some
understanding that there's a phenomena
that we have to understand and
regularize so i think right to
understand that there is weather yes you
have to construct the pathology around
that yes
it's something that's controllable
right yeah like this is i see mythology
basically as like baby knowledge right
it could be that you know although
there's lots of there's lots of alien
sight up so called alien sightings right
so there are a number of things you can
do you could just dismiss them and say
that's not true they're kind of made up
or you say well there's some there's
something interesting here right we keep
seeing a commonality right we see the
same phenomena again and again and again
also this is interesting about human
imagination
even if they are
let's not say made up but mis
misappropriated kind of other inputs
the fact that human consciousness is
capable of imagining contact with aliens
does that not tell us about something
about where we are in our position in
our culture and our technology it tells
us where in time we are could it be that
we're making contact with let's say that
so let's say let's take the most
miserable version there are no aliens in
the universe life is only on earth
that then the interpretation of that is
we're desperate to kind of understand
why we're the only life in the universe
right the other one is the other most
extreme is that aliens are visiting all
the time and we just you know we're just
not able to capture them coherently or
there's a big conspiracy and you know
there's an area 51 and there are lizards
everywhere and
there's that
um or i i'm i kind of in favor of the
idea that maybe humanity is waking up to
the idea that we aren't alone in the
universe and we're just running the
simulation
and we're seeing some evidence you know
we don't we don't know what life is yet
we are we do have some anomalies out
there
we can't explain everything
um
and over time
um you know we will start to unpack that
one very plausible thing we might do
which might be boring for the average
alien
um
observer or believes that aliens are as
intelligent aliens are visiting earth it
could be that we might go to the outer
solar system
and find a new type of life that has
completely new chemistry bring these
cells back to earth where you could say
in my hand on earth here's rna dna and
proteins and look cells self-replicate
from titan we've got this new set of
molecules new set of cells
and we feed it stuff and it grows that
for me if we were able to do that which
would be like the the most that would be
my ufo sighting that's a good test so
you feed it and it grows yeah
we've made
so not until you know how to feed the
thing
[Music]
it grows somehow we can make a comic
book you know the tiger that came for
tea the alien that came for tea
you